if they want me to be blind look I'm not
a proc comic but whoa dude wait careful
what is this a [__] Poco Loco Pollo
Loco
but that's my point that's my point dude
Poco Loco where is this Pollo Loco I
can't I can't see it smells like chicken
oh it's just Thanksgiving dude what you
it's turkey in Thanksgiving
drunk
[Music]
hello hello hello
no no no
all right dude lifeline and I got my
feet like this right up until the middle
right to so you can see the the shop you
can see my face in it see is the reason
you put those shoes up is it because you
like the bottoms of them and you want
everybody to see them no I was just
comfortable
okay and that's how it goes but I guess
I'll take the feet down dude it's good
because I'm wearing pink the bottom of
your shoes are pink but no you just
ruined it no I was pink that's red
well they're dirty so it looks better
it's dust the dust it was the wrong
poetry so it wasn't wrong dust on the
red makes it pink
um people say that I plug my dates too
much on this Tour on this uh podcast
what do you think I don't care I simply
don't care I'll tell you what let me
tell you why because we barely do any
commercials or ads so I plug my dates
okay you know how many times I hear oh
man come to Kansas City I was just in
Kansas City I do it so until that stops
happening I'm gonna plug my days okay so
I will be in Kansas City yes right okay
coming up next and I will be in
Springfield and I will be in a bunch of
different places Minneapolis and Austin
chrisley.com go get tickets Columbus
Ohio everywhere dude I'm coming
everywhere you'll be in Sugar Land Texas
no I already did that oh he already did
Sugar Land he had a great time in Sugar
Land everybody yeah yay so go ahead we
love you Sugarland uh hey and if you
want to have a one-on set one-on-one
session with me matalia your boy baby
I'm bad about it every Tuesday and
Thursday sign up make this freaking
flapping flippity session no I can't say
a bad Mormon a Mormon I can't say a bad
word okay so Mormon we're Mormon in the
first five minutes of this yeah podcast
we're Mormon so we don't say a bad word
so they don't right
so we're Mormon in the first five
minutes so we don't get to monetize and
we don't get uh messed up here is that
cool thing true or is that just a thing
people say it and I just adhere to it oh
okay I'm a follower I don't have a mind
of my own okay so it's all good
um but yeah we're having a good time
no I don't want to do that we did it
last time uh I gotta stop saying we're
having a good time honestly because
sometimes we don't even have a good time
no you have a good time doing the
podcast but when we come in often I say
we're having a good time and we don't I
don't know how what kind of time you've
been having well usually here's
something usually when I come in
everyone's head is down and everyone's
extremely rude to me for no reason today
because I called everybody out on it
the last time I was here I said you guys
are the worst ever at greeting people
okay all of you made a big deal except
one who was still a rude so prick
holdout was it still which was you I did
I I but you were doing it facetiously
Chris and Anthony meant it dude they
were doing it facetiously they were but
I could tell that they meant it you were
being facetious and evil how could you
mean it and also be physician because it
was like hey remember aha I love you
that was them this you were like oh that
was stupid
interesting yeah I didn't do it that way
no you did I did do it I found it so
unbelievably interesting uh I just think
that um you you don't have to say super
highs to everybody
that that you see all the time anyway
and do text chain with every single day
you don't but it's you do you do have to
do something other than this
when someone walks I say hey sometimes
but there are times yeah totally yeah
okay all right well I you know what I I
take accountability with that and I'm
sorry and I shouldn't do that and you're
right thank you no but don't be like
thank you because that makes you
something the way you said it is I got
my way huh okay well thank you how about
that okay okay I have my own feelings
about that that I have to work on again
and that's fine so how do you reach for
it and my tattoos itch yes yes dude
which one's new let's have it this is
new this is one news here but I'm not
done with it it's only halfway done not
gonna tell anybody what it is I didn't
even know about that I knew about that
show the world
it's a Lotus yep that's cool yeah it's
very cool
and I have another one here and I'm
getting another one actually at this
point I'll already have it because we
recorded it I'm getting it on Thursday
I'm Gonna Get You know I told you I'm
getting completely added up yes you've
mentioned that many times yeah so I'm
gonna look disgusting in a good way oh
I'll say yeah okay why did you get the
Lotus yeah no that's for me oh no
I didn't explain my tattoos
you can't get a tattoo for the world to
see and then be like I'm not telling you
what it is but it means
why would you get it because he likes
White Lotus
I have a Steve Zahn tattoo on my uh ABS
oh that's a bad that's his face and then
the text bubble coming out saying hi
Matt
so like Stevo would get I just like wake
Lotus man
um so yeah so uh yeah I'm gonna get
completely added up dude I'm gonna be a
legs guy I'm gonna be a tattoo I'm gonna
get in my tattoo I'm getting tattoos on
my legs I'm gonna do that I don't want
you to but what do I care that's fine
I'm great that's great uh sibo has a
tattoo that says what is that his him on
his back oh my god wow
wow
and then he's got something on his butt
yeah your name right oh your name what's
weird about that is how bad it is yeah
it is bad but he knows that you know and
it's fine but like uh
you know that's just weird huh he's kind
of unsettling it's not good yeah it's
bad
that's real huh wow oh yeah that's real
yeah okay well people have crazy don't
approve of it you know um would you ever
wear bracelets do you wear bracelets
I don't wear bracelets and I never have
but I don't I don't thought about that I
thought about it you what I thought
about being a bracelet guy and how
develops the Arizona yes dude um I
thought about it on the plane I was like
it would look really nice just something
like just dangling off me like that
you've worn bracelets before though no
well like when I was 20.
uh I thought about just how nice it
would look just dangling off me you know
would it look that nice dangling off of
you I mean I just feel like if I had a
bracelet on and it was like shiny it
might be like oh [__] he's got something
extra going on maybe I might look that
like you're saying you're gonna get the
cross earring yeah okay I guess [__]
jury's out everyone said that you should
get the crosshairing oh yeah really yeah
I mean I'm not gonna get it but I'm just
saying maybe if I was like the dangly I
want to be a certain type of guy and you
took my thing so it's like what do I do
now I could be guy who has the the bull
the bull what about the we talked about
the gauges you could get that no I think
those are terrible yeah yeah what else
is there you get your lip pierced no
that's I don't want a beef I don't like
piercings dude do you nose pierce no I'm
not that guy I'm not that guy are you
gonna get all over the neck and stuff
like to other places on your neck yeah I
will I told you I'm gonna do cityscape I
don't know what I'm gonna get maybe not
a City skate but I'm guessing something
like that I want you to see me and be
like whoa that guy's trouble he might
fight us you should get the cityscape of
loserville not a place or loser land all
right on your neck so that everybody
knows where you're from imagine if I got
loserville loser land
that would be the worst because I get
Stevo on my back um population one so
yeah
um uh yeah so I don't know okay well
what do you think what do I think about
jewelry you have two rings that are the
same ring yeah I like I like rings I
like the way they feel on my hand uh and
I like to do stuff with them like tap
them and punch people in the in the head
and so they get knocked out I have one
ring
Mike is unplugged again
yeah so it obviously is though because
it's sitting under chest there
is it good now yeah okay how long was it
unplugged
I don't my mic keeps getting unplugged
it's not my fault so what's going on
well considering it's happening to you
and not me somebody tells me something
that you're doing is causing it so it is
your fault or this is faulty
no Faulty Towers
stance got so offended felt it in his
heart yeah
um
I don't think they're faulty
I handmade them I am I has a tick tock
channel that has like 150 000
subscribers hand makes uh
and so um hey this is how I make podcast
equipment wow
um God I I'm not a tick tock well I was
just doing it basically but it makes me
mad flat with him
what is don't flirt with them oh that's
what song you're doing wow you didn't
know dude no no well not until you said
the don't flirt with that don't flirt
with him I'm not gonna flirt with him
that's a trend from like two years ago
uh bro I'm kind of how you build mics
you know with a hammer and sickle that's
the whole thing they're handmade I'm
joking don't flat with him I'm not gonna
flirt with him
why are you doing that song because it's
a trend dude it goes like don't flare
with him I'm not gonna flirt with him
right and then it's just a really hot
guy and she's like
it was like a picture of me like this
coming out of water no you're not that
hot
um
so yeah so anyway he didn't know what I
was doing that's funny Anthony did you
yeah
that makes me so happy I know it dude I
knew it dude I
can you do it can you play it or can we
not play it I mean we'll see okay we
might get to monitors
warnings says it doesn't seem worth it
here wow
[Music]
I hate it yeah it's awful
don't flirt with him look I'm not
I'm not okay
dude you guys are idiots you guys are
idiots no it's the record everyone here
laughed at that except me dude someone
because you don't need to get dude and
put it on someone make it yo listen turn
it off that one was funny was that one
funny no no it's stupid okay dude dude
dude someone make it like this put me on
it don't flirt with me and then have me
be like this
was your neck hurt
no dude let me do it so they can bump
right in and then okay okay go go go
post it on my thing don't flirt with me
anyhow like this
why is that this go-to sexy thing oh
cause I'm sexy a big fan don't flirt
with me
dude dude someone put it side to side
and do it do it for me thank you oh [__]
the fans come through dude the Trends on
things that goes so bad hey
that dude they hate it how about when
they do they're about mental health and
they do that oh dude for mental health
it's okay to take a mental health day
yep yeah it's not your fault it's his
fault dude how about how about how about
when hey it's never my fault it's my
dad's fault I should have done all those
things to me dude
dude I I I hate when I hate the most
right now is the
am I is this 25 and 50 and they're just
like
why are they doing that because it's a
woman that's like uh I'm 50 if you can
believe it because you're like oh you
should she always looks 50. right and
they're like haha and you know she's not
25 because she's doing the [__]
challenge anyway you know when I saw I
saw young like boys like teenage boys
doing it like if I was my dad in my
dad's yearbook when he was my age and
they had like a letterman jackets on and
they were like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but they had like nerd glasses on or
something yeah all they ever are are
people trying to look sexy look how good
looking I am yeah but they're under the
guise of like right
I'm playing along with this silly
challenge I know it's so stupid I hate
it yeah it's it's Halloween Just
everyone's dressed as hot as they can
yeah right I mean it's like one of those
things that's like I'm gonna do
something silly I'm gonna be like uh
Wario for Halloween and then it just got
like a yellow hat and like their tits
all out and they're just like it's me
it's a me Wario
yeah the ones with the young guys that
make me the most mad though because
they're just like well yeah because men
should never be doing that but they
obviously get a ton of likes otherwise
why would I be seeing them I'm not even
on dig talk yeah they get a ton of likes
but there so many of them are like
cringy and ironic
not ironic on purpose no no no no no the
people who like it are they're like oh
that's hilarious like oh really yeah I
like to see that [__] it's so funny that
somebody would stoop solo to do that
[__] we're talking about to worry about
young people man it's sad well I think
every generation worries about the youth
right no they'll I feel like every
generation hates young people they're
like when I was young it wasn't like
that we had to actually skin the animal
before yeah yeah you know but well like
I feel like bad for younger people now
everything sucks nobody's gonna have a
job everyone's gonna have an
embarrassing video of them by the time
they're trying to get a job it's just
like yeah
yeah they all are [__] but that stuff
will level out and then it'll be a new
generation and it's just like y'all are
[__] okay anyways that'll be the most
beautiful generation of all time that
will be the most pimp and pimp yeah
because they're gonna be so I don't give
a [__] it does go in Cycles so maybe
there's hope for like cow's age by the
time we're 90 yeah
like cows kids no no cow oh no Cal's age
I guess yeah cow's age so by the time um
all the hope is in you all the hope is
uh on your shoulders Cal so I can't wait
to be 60 and should just be leveled out
don't get your hopes up you know yeah
yeah cow would be like you know 20 and
you'll be so worried about him I know
dude I know being being a dad is is
tremendously stressful you know oh God
all right okay let's uh let's see what's
up
so handsome hey Lifeline guys so
beautiful my name is Greg and what's up
Greg
um my girlfriend Jules is a big fan of
Lifeline hates us and of you guys that's
great I'm sorry I don't know you guys
names uh
we watched episode 42 and I pretended
like I was gonna make a video so I can
come in the bathroom which I did and
um now I'm making a video but how do you
guys feel about pooping in a new
relationships
bathroom
yeah and not making a weird
what are your thoughts
I could tell you anytime I can tell your
thoughts another story I can tell your
thoughts of the story would you like to
hear a story dude don't flat with me no
no no no no dude I think would you like
to hear a story oh yeah okay
so when I was uh uh God
I might have been only 18 years old and
now I lived in New York I was going to
school in New York but my girlfriend
lived out here in LA and she
visited me a couple times and when I
came back to LA with the first time I
visited her at her like off-campus
apartment whatever yeah she went to USC
and thank you and uh but I was
technically staying with Mom and Dad
because they lived close and her she had
this tiny little apartment and we had
just started dating actually oh I know
this story so uh wake up early in the
morning and
um again new relationship I had to Grump
it out didn't want to Grump it out right
next to my new beautiful girlfriend who
is sleeping beautifully right next to
where the bathroom is I didn't want her
to know I was going to bump it out she
knew I had to leave early anyway under
any normal circumstance I would have
just grumped it out you know what I'm
saying sure
and uh
I was like I'll manage this home is only
like 15 minutes away poetry I get in the
car and immediately on the 110 I hit
traffic
now I'm like okay this is getting pretty
bad I'm like looking for places to maybe
pull over or going to a gas station try
to Grump it out in one of those
disgusting yeah and what I realized is
like by the time I pull off with all the
traffic and get to a gas station that's
only gonna be like a couple minutes less
time than I would be to get all the way
back home okay
so I'm just like all right I'm just
going to do it I'm committing I'm going
to go home and I'm just going to make it
unfortunately I'm like by the time I'm
just about to get on off on the off ramp
I'm I'm just like I'm I'm doing the
thing where like I'm
literally looking at myself in the
rearview mirror right yelling at me by
name saying I'm like come on yeah yeah
come on Matt like don't get sit your pet
you can't you can't Grump it out right
now Perry movie you know and uh I'm just
like I'm like kinda standing yeah
because like if I sit it's just bad news
okay so I'm like as tense as I can you
know come on Man Randy Savage Oh yeah
slim jim and then I get off the freeway
I get home and I'm just about pulling
into their driveway and I'm just like I
don't know if it's like the brain
relenting because you know you're close
or whatever but it's getting worse and
worse and worse and I I realize as I'm
parking like I now have to move right
and there's no moving when you have to
go this back of course the first
movement
there she blows okay okay so I step out
of the car yeah and and my and Mom
happened to be out for in front of the
house yeah and so um yeah open the door
I'm gonna go to bathroom and I say step
out of the car it's just like
there she blows what okay but I like it
was like just like a like a mushroom
cloud because I had to like a little bit
out you know and then so and I saw just
like this I was just like
and I finally get to the bathroom and
mom is like dying
and I had to like throw everything away
but I threw mom away we sold the house
and everything
um got rid of the car so uh but yeah she
their girlfriend never found out so wow
jokes on who dude I think by the way
like And subscribe
um I think honestly that um
I think that it's you here I had a
friend
that said texted me recently it was
maybe a month ago maybe not even he was
like hey man what do I do if I just I'm
over at uh my
I know what you're gonna say about the
house her house I'm seeing her and for
the first time and I gotta go number two
he's like do you do it and I'm like yeah
man just do it he did it texted me
you're not gonna believe this the toilet
doesn't work oh what like a Matthew
Perry movie dude in 1990 you know what I
mean or 2002. so I'm like oh my God so I
was like what do I do I guess I gotta
try and fix it he and I was like dude
just go tell her go be like yo I I took
a grump in the in the toilet yeah that I
didn't know it was broken you should
have told me like what the [__] I'm the
man though yeah that's what you say to
her and he was like really and I was
like yeah just do that who cares only
she'll think you're sexy if you own it
and he's like and then I gotta text a
little bit later he's like I fixed it
yeah I wanted him to not be able to fix
it oh wow so he got away with not
telling her I'm pissed off no good for
him no why
why did you want him to get busted for
grumping it out into her toilet because
I hate my friends oh okay well that now
I don't know why I don't know I don't
know why but it's okay to do poop in
your uh girlfriend's toilet in the
beginning well yeah totally I mean the
moral of my story is just go yeah but
also what's up with the dude he was
saying wait but real quick look I was 19
when I that you sir look like you're
pushing 40 you should know by now that
you just gotta do it it's like what's
the big deal it's like you just got
humans go to the bathroom what is she
gonna think you never poop
like that's not what a human does
yeah what's the what's the thing yeah
but you don't want you don't want them
to smell your brand of poop but like
that's stupid
every brand of poop is bad who's got
like a great [__] brand
no you have a terrible [__] that's not
true you have the one of the worst [__]
Brands I've ever even laid my nose on is
that true yeah it is dude you the thing
about you and your brand of shooting is
that you [__] right after you eat it's
like an open vessel it's just like one
big pipe inside your body yeah it just
comes right out just like an elevator
yeah yeah
uh don't flirt with me
Dumb and Dumber
I just don't know man uh basically I
think that you do it also was the guy
saying he wasn't a fan or he was joking
but if he wasn't wow so wanted to get
back and that's cool so long you've been
trying to get back to that part about he
was making a joke that he doesn't know
what our names are okay cool he does of
course he does I know he's not going to
submit a a video Yeah asking about
taking shits at his girlfriend's house
when he doesn't know who the people are
he was pretty handsome I wonder if his
uh if they broke up if you got a chance
no I wonder yeah I want to date him
um I think he's got a lot of leeway with
his brand of [__] could be really bad
because he's handsome yeah because he's
so handsome yeah put it put your brand
of [__] on another person who is an
attractive thing uh you might be worse
off yeah you're bad you're all right bro
you're all right you're doing good okay
so dark hey Matt and Chris love the uh
the show love the content oh hates it
I'm looking Inward and I think that I I
think the problem is me oh shoot just
got even darker okay but shoot you
didn't start uh get out yet so yeah just
lost in time and space but uh but anyway
uh Vehicles when they're when they're um
behind me Vehicles so proper uh cars uh
with their headlights they have uh
halogen lights and the lights are
they're allowed to be they're legally
allowed to have them that you know
fluorescent uh uh like that blue because
we're walking the blue tent but yet it's
like
and they chose that you know what I mean
like and like the truck and this is I
have a problem but the truck The Wheels
on the side nurses are like sticking out
they made that choice yeah
you know what I mean so someone made
choices to this to This SUV they've
converted this thing okay
and one of the choices is the halogen
lights halogen they're so annoying like
it's just so bright and you can't you
can't escape it you can just like close
your eyes but yeah why would someone do
that okay does that how do I
um you know what I mean nope
how do you what that's the end if it
bothers you that much pull over slow
down get behind the car no escaping
halogen lights no that's that's what you
need advice about you're living large
dude that is the least concerning
situation about the question how do you
escape halogen lights yes close your
eyes also the notifications that stick
out not if you're driving well yeah but
then he's saying if you're driving in
the car behind you has the halogen
halogen lights this pulp pull over
yeah I guess right yeah or anything that
much or anything else I've got sincere
problems or also here's what you got to
work on not the halogen light thing
halogen light thing but you got to work
on that because he was saying it like
that well you got to work on is saying
words in the right order and and I don't
know
this kind of thing with I might be the
one with the problem
and then talk about how dark it is where
you are and then at the very end only
then reveal what your question even is
yeah hey um so yeah I just got a
question oh man I might be the problem
Oh God it got so dark halogen the lights
what's up
yeah dude that's the worst
this guy honestly uh uh this guy
literally has has killed at least two
people in that lot he was parked in at
the time I'm gonna say get out of my
country guy even though he's born here
oh wow go ahead yeah I'm racist against
a white guy next one that's okay
sleeping
what's up guys
can't wait to uh hear what you guys say
about my uh patchy beard and whatnot but
I just love you man been following you
for a minute uh Matt you're [__]
hilarious thank you man
um weird question I'm watching this
weird movie and uh it's a good movie
um it's called about time I don't know
oh yeah like uh Rachel McAdams anyway
get on with it you know what I mean
um
why do the British people wear like
um George Washington uh wigs and [__]
when they're in court yeah why do they
still do that right like it's so dumb
really dumb like even in 2023 they're
still wearing like
wigs dude what so bad I'm [__]
yeah
you know
wow just wanted to show us his tattoo
the fact that there's people that are
being annoying out there in the real
world because of [__] that we say is
unbelievable
[Laughter]
um that's the cult dude uh yeah it's
ridiculous and I always think as a
matter of fact I just found this out I
was watching a TV show and they went to
court in Britain and they had the wigs
on and I was like oh is this like a
dystopian show or what you didn't think
that was going on and I was like they
still do this also the lawyers do it too
it's not just the judges it's it's it's
uh dude it's it's it's actually
so many more places used to do the same
thing Traditions are awful but so many
like African countries your other
European countries Australia New Zealand
all these countries used to do the same
thing the only one that still does it is
the UK Britain
is so dope except for it sucks because
of the tradition if it did just drop
this [__] it would be so much better
the problem with the wigs is they're so
dumb looking they're dumb they honestly
you should have a dildo coming out of
their head like this dude you know why
you know why people started doing that
in the first place it wasn't even judges
it was like a high society because of
the [__] disgusting how disgusting
their hair would smell no close though
what
they there was sometimes because of lice
but they think the main reason was
because so many people had syphilis and
one of the symptoms of syphilis one of
the main ones that everyone got man and
woman was random hair loss like patches
and no one wanted it to be seen no one
so everyone that had it started wearing
it wear a hat well there weren't hats
back then I guess there were but like
you couldn't wear a hat inside and [__]
hello oh right you know hello
um I can't stop [__] my hands
here's the thing we're not gonna stop
[__] right so we lose an eye in real
really weird random places on our heads
wigs that's what we're gonna do they're
all gonna be white [__] is hat nonsense
camera that was inside
braided wigs braided big wigs and
powder you know with the rosy cheeks do
you know what they're made out of here
[Laughter]
[__] man it might be the kid the use
will grow up not wearing eggs but I
cannot do that
I mean how happy was everybody when
somebody came up with the thing that got
rid of syphilis dude how annoying is it
that they still are like all right is
what we're gonna have go on uh you're on
trial for murder I don't think you've
done it all right I'm gonna be your
lawyer I'm gonna [__] fight your case
and we're gonna get you off and you're
going to be free now let's go to court
hahaha
[Music]
is it straight or what is it it's
crooked hold on hold on oh you count
your handcuffed here let me get that I'm
so done with your handcuffs in in court
you know they got these against the
thing you know where you're like that oh
look in the mirror and the other cops
are watching the lawyer do it because
it's a two-way mirror
all right let's go lawyers don't usually
wear it anymore
they can it's not it's not required I
like to do it still you can I like to do
it a lot of female and minority judges
do it because they it like some it
symbolizes that we're all equal in the
eyes of the law I like to do it on black
and I like to do it because it
symbolizes well just taking the exact
words I said you're all equal
literally just saying black woman just
saying the words I said I'm a black
woman but well I was born a woman but I
think I'm a man I'm trans and I'm also
a little person a barrister oh equal in
a lot can you say little people Little
People is what that's what it is yeah oh
okay you shouldn't say m-i-d-g-e-t yeah
okay you know you don't have to spell it
out well uh I just I actually didn't
know what the little people is the one
okay okay relax you can either call you
can either call them that or it's
politically correct either call them out
or when you see them go oh
so dumb
yeah that's our next one all right
a killer love Lifeline love
congratulations and based on your
specific advice before it spins the
deeper for me um I had a specific uh
question that I wanted to ask you all
the whole windshield um I've been
dealing on and off with
um with nicotine addiction I've been
smoking cigarettes ever since I was
about 17. I was just trying to find out
based on some of the solutions that
people have brought to me that have not
been
um very helpful to me well how would you
suggest getting off cigarettes and
nicotine in a more natural way again
love your podcast uh and I'm always
going to be with you Chris and Matt
through these trying times and uh I
appreciate it oh yeah dude
um I honestly think it's a lot of it has
to do with an oral fixation so start uh
giving moral sex
then again what do you know because you
never had a cigarette in your life no I
know but I I feel like I you know
sweetie oh sweetie I want a cigarette
and then what you go down on her
oh okay yeah that's okay I need a
cigarette or if you're gay even better
because it's like a cigarette okay
um yeah
the only times I've been able to stop
smoking is is at the times that I
actually want to do it if I just I'm
like oh it's because of my health or oh
it's because of this person I'm dating
doesn't like it I'll be like this in the
corner
and does act like I didn't do it right
you know what I mean but like so
obviously did it because it smells like
well yeah sure what's up how's it going
did you smoke yeah
and then it's over yeah uh but yeah if
you don't want to do it it's probably
not actually gonna happen so give up and
save yourself the end it doesn't sound
like he wants to do it though exactly so
don't quit
no no I'm saying it does want to quiz oh
oh oh oh dude what's the you you you
know the the what's the name of that
book that everyone says is great Alan
carbuck yeah yeah that's a great book
what's the name of it uh yes what the
name was right now the easy way to quit
smoking there you go there's a book
called the easy way to quit smoking by
Alan Carr is that his name yeah I think
so yeah and uh apparently I've heard
like several people say that the only
thing that got them to quit smoking is
this book that's crazy I never read the
book uh I don't know but too seriously
like at least five people have told me
that what's on me dude it's weird yeah
yeah it worked on you yeah it's like
hypnosis in a book yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah repeating the same thing and then
you start thinking don't smoke don't
smoke don't smoke don't smoke don't
smoke don't smoke don't smoke stop
smoking don't smoke what the wow that's
crazy chapter five don't smoke all right
what else who else we got
sick Missy Elliott jacket what up Matt
and Chris what's the drillio I live in
Germany I'm stationed here I'm in the
military yes thank you thank you for
four and a half years been with my
girlfriend who's a German cool for three
years cool uh and I love her oh cute my
issue is I get out of the military in
June and then it's time for me to find a
civilian job
um
uh there's there are jobs for me in
Germany but not as many as there are for
me in the United Kingdom
so my question is should I
uh accept a job in Germany so that I can
stay in Germany which is where I want to
be
but the job might not pay what I wanted
to and it might not be what I want uh to
be doing
or should I go to the United Kingdom
where I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get a
well-paying job and it's going to be
something that I want to do
I don't want to do a long distance thing
uh because I just kind of don't think
they work so basically the
it's basically if I move away we break
up sadness
what should I do thanks I mean stay yeah
you know if you don't yeah I mean maybe
the job may not be high paying enough uh
and that's okay because it's also you're
in the place you want to be in and then
number two you don't have to break up
with your uh give me going on for four
years three years the woman that you're
in love with and then also
um and then also uh the other thing I
was gonna say is uh
um
I don't remember go ahead yeah I just
you probably can always go to if you can
get a job now that's good and high
paying or better paying than the one you
would maybe get in Germany I'm assuming
that would also be true in like six
months a year or whatever but if you
start out in Germany with possibly the
worst job oh yeah but you get to be with
the woman you love what if you realize
that that lifestyle is amazing yeah and
you don't have to risk losing the love
of your life like I I don't think see if
you can I I get what you're seeing yeah
exactly start out in the Germany because
this is why you don't have to move it's
all the logistics and [__] the potential
the in the two different spots the best
potential
the most potential is in Germany it
seems like it to me too yeah you'll have
to try that first your girlfriend you're
doing fought
because he's moving sure doing what
you're moving but also can't she move to
you the UK well I don't know it depends
on we don't know we don't know she might
be like have a really great job right
okay yeah she might not she might not
speak British you should have said that
yeah true he definitely should have it I
thought that while he was saying he's
like you should definitely yeah he
should have addressed that at least
obvious thing that we would ask right
right I mean maybe she's out there maybe
she like [__] does the she loves like
the what are the the festivals the
[__] October Oktoberfest okay wow or
maybe she makes
um you know I don't know doesn't know
anything needs my help for every single
one of the jokes or whatever what
benches yeah Germany's renowned for
their wooden benches we make wooden
punches this is what we do look at this
how comfortable to say oh oh boy look at
this one uh you could fit nine in this
one uh this kind of sounds actually no
that sounds yeah yeah okay all right so
don't [__] with me actually okay all
right next next one
Mario Lopez man Chris long time listener
first time caller I'm wondering about
um elevator manners okay when you're
going up in an elevator and just one
stranger hops on that ride with you are
you supposed to chat with him shoot the
phrase small talk all that stuff
um I work in an office on the 15th floor
and I generally hate when people try
talking to me yeah not a fan of small
talk not a fan of
I don't know just giving information to
some random yeah person
um but it seems like a really common
thing at least where I'm at
um I usually try to keep headphones in
to avoid that at all costs so yeah what
do you guys think what's the best way to
do that should I be more sociable try to
converse with with random folks or you
don't have to you're gonna have it all
right look here's what you do so when
you say both of you need to relax
because who cares just do it for the
amount of time you're on there like
don't worry about it just get on the
elevator if someone talks to you just be
like oh yeah and that's it you don't
have to like be like oh I got to put my
headphones oh I gotta pretend I'm
texting true oh I gotta pretend I'm on
the phone that takes up too much that is
true but I wish that I wish that I was
not famous sometimes so I could just be
like I don't speak English you can do
this you can do that and that would be
awesome to do it sorry I don't speak
English I don't know words except for
these ones I'm about to say I cannot
talk to you here in elevator that's like
the joke in that uh episode of the
critic remember that we laughed so hard
no he gets into his uh taxi cab and he
says like a bunch of directions uh-huh
and and the Cabbage turns around in a
perfect English he's like Pakistanian
middle but in perfect English she says
read the sign and it's just oh I love
drive around in those three words oh
yeah I read the sign yeah yeah okay wow
so mad no that's great okay
that's cool I mean John loves had a cool
little cartoon I guess wow no but I oh
this is what you can do and this is the
most gangster thing you can do okay
you're in the
elevator or you're somewhere somebody
comes up to you and talks to you without
doing anything different you just look
at him and say sorry I'm on the phone
[Laughter]
I mean you can do anything
yeah yeah uh-huh yep yep actually you
know what you could do that no that's
crazy because they could think they
would think I just had some technology
thing I don't see right yeah now that
would actually work if you if you do
that with confidence that would work
like this and they say we're talking
about yeah
technology moves much faster than you
think just like that with nothing in
your hands yeah
hey Matt so hopefully you guys can help
me with this problem that I've been
having because honestly I'm at a loss at
this point so any advices would be very
helpful I know I know so I just moved
into this new place and the neighbors
right next door to me uh have this
exotic bird
oh
it showed up right on cue I don't know
if you can hear that it's going off
right now it's incredibly loud
um I mean the wall is kind of dampen the
sound a bit but it's so quiet otherwise
around here that it's so freaking loud
when it goes off in addition to that
they also have this muscle car which
they don't actually use they just uh
every once in a while rev it up and it's
just like so obnoxious because whenever
they do that then it kind of Rawls up
the bird and it's just annoying so the
latest I've heard this bird make noise
is like 8 30 maybe nine o'clock at the
very latest okay
um but usually it's going crazy in the
afternoon luckily I'm gone most days so
it doesn't matter but it just gets
annoying sometimes when you're trying to
have some peace and quiet you know what
I mean yeah also for a little bit of
context
um all the neighbors pretty much hate
these guys they're like yeah the most
hated person oh [__] yeah and people
have called the cops on them and the
cops have never done any bird cops come
so that's kind of where I'm at and you
know I'm always trying to be positive
about things and trying to understand
that everybody's going through their own
stuff
um but it just seems so selfish in my
opinion anyways help me out put the bird
in the car drive the car off a cliff
but the guys but the rental car put the
guys in the car drive the car with the
cliff uh the car thing I can relate to
my neighbor who is
has a an old like vintage vehicle that I
don't even want to call a car because he
doesn't ever drive it anywhere but he
does just rev it once every week or two
because it's like he's gotta like keep
it fresh that's stupid you don't take it
anywhere you [__]
I don't uh just but the bird thing is
like
dude that is
you got to be such a Titanic [__]
just to get a loud exotic bird when you
live in an apartment don't stop it you
got to be a gigantic [__] to have a
bird yeah if you live in seclusion
though like fine but if you live among
people
very in very close quarters you're such
a dick dude yeah you are a dick it's
like it makes you want to cry like how
could you be that bad of a person what
the [__] is wrong with you show this to
your neighbor yeah Billy Joe from Green
Day what the [__] is wrong with you
owning that bird also you're ruining
life for everybody
also
you know with the car
it's I think it's fine with the car if
you're gonna drive the car if you're not
gonna drive the car just rev it it's not
cool look I have a throw mobile okay
there is no what what I've my car's
throaty when I started well that's not a
thing
that's what it's called well I call it
that nobody's ever said throaty do you
guys know what thrody is I know it just
because he said okay so you made it up
okay but I drive it dude and my car is
very cool and I drive it okay so now see
what you did was you only wanted to talk
about that you have a cool car no okay
it's not what I want because it's not
anything like what he was having Throat
Mobile and what I do with it is drive it
I don't just sit there and rev it that's
awful if you're sitting there and
revving it you're just being an [__]
to the people around you right and when
I turn the reason is to keep it fresh
and up it doesn't get old it doesn't get
like that's fine what do you call it
yeah but just drive it yeah I agree I
mean I agree I have a throat mobile and
it's a fantastic vehicle and I only turn
it on to drive it and a matter of fact
whenever I turn on to drive it I still
feel bad
I also have two modes one can go quiet
mode one can go large mode and I go
quiet mode a lot large mode
that's not what it's called
is it really quiet mode though quiet
mode and why do you ever not be in quiet
mode I don't you're always in quiet mode
pretty much unless I'm on the open
[__] freeway and I'm just killing it
boom boom it's a throw mobile dude you
got to [__] take advantage
Senator all right all right cool let's
do it next onesie Ponzi
uh I want to start off by saying thank
you so much for everything for all your
hard work all your advice it's been
wildly helpful thank you uh Chris you've
gotten me through some messed up stuff
sorry to hear you got me through High
School uh never failed to put a smile on
my phone so thank you so much
um thank you guys happy to be here for
you uh so uh I'm officially 185 pounds
down I've lost almost 200 pounds
completely changed health-wise and
especially physically oh my prior to
losing the weight people were really
awful to me sometimes I mean like I bet
they're kissing your ass now awful so
the most ruthless evil out of pocket
stuff yeah
um and a lot of it became kind of
drilled into my head yeah uh and I
started to believe a lot of it and often
still do and because of that I'm
horrible at receiving and accepting
compliments to the point where I'll just
be like you're lying oh yeah okay no
when somebody compliments me or says
that I'm pretty for example and that's
awful and it's super rude and it's
invalidating and uh it's not me and um
it's just trauma it's a deeper so if you
guys could help me be a little bit more
or try to be a little bit more receptive
to these compliments I would really
appreciate it because I don't want to
come across as
a jerk yeah thank you all right the the
negative stuff is drilled into your head
because you thought those people meant
what they said and it hurt your feelings
you thought they meant what they said
because they said it
people are giving you compliments now
you can't just decide that the people
who were mean meant it and the people
who are nice don't mean it if people say
things that are mean and mean it when
they say nice things they definitely
mean it so take the nice thing and keep
it and let it lay on you just like you
do with the mean stuff that they were
saying before it's all the same value
like you just you're just like
discarding it because the stuff before
was negative but the things people say
whether good or bad need to carry the
same truth value otherwise it's
inconsistent and that's just not fair to
yourself so you have to remind yourself
that that holds as much weight as the
stuff that hurt before so let that [__]
make you feel good because they mean it
they're not saying it just to they're
not saying it for any other reason then
then they mean it when you popped up I
said now we're talking because I thought
nice things so yeah she's beautiful yeah
uh that's yeah that's true you're that
was very astute and um you know I would
have said that but probably a little bit
better in a better way I think that
that's really really that's it I mean we
are geared to see to think the negative
[__] you know it sucks but yeah you're
right actually that helps me because you
know people
I don't know you got to let it all in
either let it all in or let it don't let
it in you know but they're not you don't
let people tell you how you are anyway
you got to know how you are which is a
very sweet you seem like a very sweet
caring person and um and that's who you
are so [__] these [__] both
ways you're you that being said it does
make sense that you that the harmful
hateful ones that really hurt stick with
you because we're still animals and
animals are wired
memory is a direct descendant of pain
pain creates memories because when you
are hurt you just think oh I don't want
that to happen again
investing energy and remembering to have
that thing happen oops right and uh a
good thing is just naturally less
important to survival because you don't
need it to keep living not about
survival oops but in this case we've
evolved far enough that it actually is
necessary to your survival right you
need to remember the good things to have
a life that you enjoy to feel good about
yourself because it's true it's not some
[__] you're making up these people
actually think it you know it's because
it's just true they're just observing
you know yeah I'll go one further the
people that are saying the awful things
to you they don't even mean it because
they're more upset with themselves
anybody that's likely to mean less
likely yeah for sure any time someone
says some hateful [__] it's because
of them dude it's because of what
they're going through what kind of
person looks at someone says yo you're
fat somebody who's upset at the world or
themselves yeah otherwise we have
something to do with you why would you
say that to somebody yeah there's no
reason you know you're pissed but yeah I
get it my heart goes out to you that's
rough to deal with you know you being uh
traumatized in that way you know
everything that isn't nurturing is
trauma that's what some people believe
but um yeah so people doing that
traumatize you over a long period of
time and now it's hard to take a
compliment you're not this is all normal
stuff yeah but you're a unique
individual and uh and let that
let that sink in
let that let that dabble do you you know
what I mean no you ruined everything you
said that was beautiful all right who's
next and let that double do you
what's up man Chris this is Nate here
from Central Minnesota land of 10 000
lakes that means Chris I'll be seeing
you April 1st baby oh yeah so my
question revolves around anxiety and job
interviews here so um I'm just finishing
up nursing school here and um I'm gonna
be starting some interviews with some
hospitals and so one thing I do know is
that they'll have a panel of roughly
eight or so people and
um and you so sometimes you just feel
like you're under a microscope and that
gives me crazy anxiety and everything
that makes me qualified kind of goes out
the window so my first question is
um how how do I deal with the
preliminary anxiety leading up to an
interview with the hospital and my
second question probably most important
is how do I reframe my mind to put me on
a Level Playing Field with some of the
interviewers so I feel comfortable and I
can really show who I am
you know to get the job thanks guys
appreciate it I Used to Know
what what good advice I forgot I used to
know how to do this and I forgot those
people
they're intimidating to you
because you are the outsider and they
hold the key to the Future that you want
okay you want to go no go ahead uh but
they're just like you they just happen
to be on that side of the table what I'm
saying is the more you realize that that
person is the same as you in terms of
value
it's not that hard when we go into an
interview like that where the stakes are
high
and their decision
about us is like a big thing in our
lives we tend to think that they hold
some power over us but they actually
don't if you want to reframe your mind
that's all you really need to realize
that those people all eight of them five
and whatever you said are all just the
same as you they're just on the other
side of the table you here's what people
don't realize you've already won
because
when I realized I used to do auditions I
haven't gotten more jobs than you'll
ever not get okay right I used to not
get jobs because I would go in I said
they're seeing so many guys how do I
know I'm right for the part this and
that that and this
they what I when I realized this it
changed not only how I felt about doing
it but also the jaw I would get more
jobs
they want you the other side of the
table wants you to be the person that so
badly they don't want to have to sit
there and keep interviewing people they
want this on a job interview to be the
last one they want you to sit there they
want you to come in and they want you to
be like oh [__] yeah that's the guy
that's already what they're thinking so
you're playing with house money baby and
once you realize that you've already won
okay because people go to job interviews
and they're going they're all going
thinking what you're thinking whether
it's conscious or subconscious but if
you go in and you actually realize oh
they want me to be the guy
you're already the guy dude you've got
such a leg up
that's it when I started going into
auditions and I was like oh dude they
want the guy they want me to be the guy
yeah I'm gonna walk in and I'm gonna do
a hell of an acting job if I had to play
a pirate oh my God you know what I mean
yeah [__] she's [__] wow right
imagine me saying walk the plank
community
or if they want me to be British hello
Governor what's going on if they want me
to be blind look I'm not a proc comic
but whoa dude wait but careful what is
this a [__] Poco Loco Pollo Loco
but that's my point that's my point dude
where is this Pollo Loco I can't I can't
see it smells like chicken oh it's just
Thanksgiving dude what you it's turkey
in Thanksgiving so what what you what
you need to do is realize you've already
won and you're the guy dude I'm
basically that guy who talks like this
yes
um yeah yeah and they want you this is
how you know
they want you to be the guy okay just to
put a cherry on top no one really wants
to be anywhere and certainly no one
wants to be at work yep they want to go
home give them a reason to go home or at
least give them a reason to check out so
they don't have to listen to the other
people who come in go go in sit down and
be like you guys can go home and they
say what is it yeah exactly exactly yeah
take a long sip like that
spill a little bit and then before you
get to it say do you guys have a napkin
or something like that wow wipe it you
really milk it wipe it and then be like
this I'm the guy and then go like this
so as far as you can until the door and
if you have to keep scooting a little
bit you go all the way to the door and
then get out and then leave the only
thing about that is that if they don't
have a rolly chair bring your own rolly
chair or have your own realtor just
outside the door so if you walk in and
see they don't have a really interesting
one second oh yeah oh [__] guys um
actually be right back yeah or bring a
buddy yeah bring a buddy to carry to
bring the rolling chair in oh right
and then just like this you look at the
chair and say like this hey guys go home
this is how it goes go home
you guys do a napkin
thanks
oh wow I mean this is really hey yeah
bring the Royal children thank you
paraplegic wow wow wow
carrying a big marlin what you just did
what carrying a big Marlin Marlin
like a big fish like a big fish dumb of
all things no wow I'm smart I'm not dumb
okay so it's not so what I said wasn't
dumb
because I'm not that
you imagine watching that happen I mean
I would be crying I would be out of
breath and then I would die
people with no sense of humor that like
just work for a company they'd just be
like
he's okay all right yeah they would be
saying words before he got to the next
thing yeah
all right oh he's got the job and then
just like who who was that one yeah
she's got the job he's gonna be great
here Kaiser Permanente
all right that's it yeah I think that's
it that was good we got it yeah we did
it all right
thank you very much for Lifeline
chrissy.com for tickets Minnesota Austin
Texas I'll be there mad today.com for
one-on-one sessions Tuesday Thursday
[Music]
hello
hello hello
[Music]